when we started out we had no stars we
had no power or muscle we didn't have
enough money really to do what we wanted
to do but what we had was a script that
inspired mad love in everyone who read
it we had a genius for a director we had
a cast and a crew who were unwavering in
their commitment and whose talents are
up on the screen for all of you to see
we had
Partners in film 4 and celador in patham
Fox Searchlight who had the courage to
support us and we had a shared love for
the extraordinary city of Mumbai where
we made the movie most of all we had
passion and we had belief in our film
shows that if you have those two things
truly anything is possible I want to
thank on a personal note my mum and my
dad for all their love and support over
the years
I want to thank my girls saskia mulda
who's my partner in crime and the light
in my life and I want to thank all of
you very much indeed